We are going to spend
the rest of this lecture
by looking into an interesting
subclass of Markov chains
for which steady-state
convergence exists--
the class of birth
and death processes.
So what is a birth
and death process?
It's a Markov
chain whose diagram
looks like this-- the
states of the Markov chain
start from zero and go to
some finite integer number m.
And if you are at a typical
state in the middle, say i.
Then next you will
either go to the right--
or up by one unit-- or
you will go to the left--
or down by one unit-- or
you will stay where you are.
And this will happen with
the following transition
probabilities-- here p i--
i function of the state--
here q i.
And this one the remaining
1 minus p i minus q i.
So it's like keeping track
of some animal population.
Animals get born.
They die.
The assumption here is
that at any point in time,
either one animal gets born, or
one dies, or nothing happens.
There are no multiple
deaths, no births
happening at the same time.
There are many
practical applications
where this structure provides
a basic first-level model.
An example of a
chain of this kind of
was the supermarket
counter example
that we discussed before,
where the states represented
the number of
customers in a queue.
A customer arrives and the
queue increases by one.
A customer leaves and the
queue decreases by one.
Or nothing happens and
the queue stays as it is.
Now, in this supermarket
example, the p's and the q's
were all taken to be the
same across the states.
But we can generalize.
For example, the
departure rate, q,
could be different
from state to state.
For example, with lots of
customers in the queue,
perhaps the clerk
will work faster.
Such a chain can also be used
to model the spread of disease
in a population.
For example, the states could
represent the number of people
in a given population
that have the flu.
One more person gets the flu.
The count goes up.
One more person gets healed.
The count goes down.
These probabilities, in
such an epidemic model,
will certainly depend
on the current state.
If lots of people
already have the flu,
the probability that
another person catches it
would be pretty high.
But if no one has the
flu, then the probability
that one gets a transition--
where someone catches the flu--
would be pretty small.
The rate at which new people
get the disease definitely
depends on how many
people already have it.
And that motivates cases
where those p's, here,
depend on the
state of the chain.
There are lots of
other applications
for which these special
Markov chains are useful.
So how do we study them?
Such a chain consists of a
single aperiodic recurrent
class, and so has a well-defined
steady-state behavior.
To calculate the
steady-state probability
pi of i of a state i,
you can write the system
of m linear
equations in the pi's
that we had discussed before.
But this may be cumbersome,
and in fact, more work than one
actually needs to do.
There is a very
clever shortcut that
applies to birth
and death processes.
And it's based on the
frequency interpretation
that we discussed
in a recent clip.
To see this, let's
draw a line somewhere
in the middle of
this chain, and focus
on the transitions between this
left part and this right part.
Assume that the line
cuts through the middle
of two adjacent states, i
and i plus one, like here.
And so you zoom here
and this is the picture
of what you have here.
So what is the
chain going to do?
Let's say it starts on the left.
It's going to move around.
And at some point, it makes a
transition to the other side,
going here.
And that is a transition
from i to i plus 1.
And now, once it's
on the right side,
it's going to move
around as well.
And then at one point, it will
come back to that part again.
And this is a transition
from i plus one to i,
and so on and so forth.
Now, there is a certain balance
that must be obeyed here.
The number of upward transitions
through this line cannot be
very different from the number
of downward transitions from
this line.
Because if we cross
this way, then
in order to cross
again this way,
you will have first to
cross down the other way.
You can not go up 100 times
here, in that direction,
and go down here 50 times.
If you have gone
up 100 times, it
means that you have gone down
99, 100 or 101, but nothing
different from that.
So the long-term frequency with
which transitions of these kind
occur has to be the same
as the long-term frequency
that transitions
of that kind occur.
Or, in this diagram, the
frequency of that kind
has to be the same as the
frequency of that kind.
So what are these frequencies?
We discussed that before.
The fraction of times at
which transitions of this kind
are observed is the
fraction of time
that we happen to be at that
state, which is pi of i.
And out of the times that we
are in that state, the fraction
of time that transitions of
that time happen is p of i.
So the overall frequency
will be pi i times p of i.
And with the same argument,
this is the frequency
with which transitions
of that kind
are observed-- pi i
plus 1 times q i plus 1.
Since these two
frequencies are the same,
we get an equation that relates
pi of i to pi of i plus 1,
like this.
So this is the frequency
that we observed here,
of this transition.
And these are the frequencies
of these transitions.
And they have to be equal.
This has a nice form, because
it gives us a recursion.
If we knew pi i, we can
calculate pi i plus 1 as such.
So it's a system
of equations that's
easier to solve than
the original system
of linear equations
which we presented before
for a general Markov chain.
But how do we get started?
If we knew pi of 0, then we
could use it to find pi of 1.
Then from pi of 1, you can
get pi of 2, pi of 3, etc.
But we don't know pi of 0.
It's one more unknown.
It's an unknown and we
need to actually use
the extra normalization
conditions
that the sum of all the pi
j, has to be equal to 1.
After we use that
normalization condition,
then we can find all of the pi
by first solving for pi of 0.
How?
This can be returned
pi 0 plus pi 1,
which is pi 0 times p0
over q1 plus pi of 2, which
is pi of 1 times p1 over
q2, pi of 0 times p0 times
p1 over q1 times q2, which is
pi 2, plus et cetera equals 1.
This equation allows
us to find pi of 0.
And then we use this recursion
to find pi of 1, pi of 2,
pi 3, et cetera.